UFOs are real we have proof the United
States military has been studying them
there's one case in particular that I
can't stop thinking about if this case
from November 2004 off the coast of
California the military report from the
day tells a story of this blue sky
unlimited visibility day if an aircraft
carrier that detects quote multiple
anomalous aerial Vehicles descending
very rapidly from 60 000 feet down to 50
feet in a matter of seconds these flying
things just hover they stay stationary
on the radar for a short time and then
they depart at high velocities and turn
rates so they sent out these Pilots to
go
going on and they actually got video of
this stuff the report describes it as an
elongated Tic Tac shape about 47 feet in
length solid white smooth with no edges
or wings as a journalist I am incredibly
skeptical of all things paranormal okay
do we have proof that there are
extraterrestrials visiting our world no
but what we do know is that